australia's immigration minister has
cancelled
tennessee's visa just days ahead of the
australian open championship on health
grounds
djokovic who was unvaccinated first had
his visa revoked last week after landing
in australia but a judge overturned the
ruling and allowed the world number one
tennis player to stay because he had
been given a vaccine exemption
australian prime minister scott morrison
released the following statement saying
i understand that following careful
consideration action is being taken by
the minister to cancel mr djokovic's
visa held on health and good order
grounds on the basis that it was in the
public interest to do so he added that
australians have made many sacrifices
during this pandemic and they rightly
expect the results of those sacrifices
to be protected
sarah clark joins us now live from
brisbane sarah have we heard anything
then from novak djokovic or his legal
team
we haven't heard anything from novak and
his uh djokovic and his legal team as
yet but we do expect them to appeal this
decision and based on that we do expect
them to take it back potentially to the
federal circuit court in melbourne over
the weekend now the alex hawk the
immigration minister he always held
these discretionary powers and to
overrule that court decision and as a
result he did he pursued that the
government has always stood its ground
and said that rules are rules uh we want
uh we will will upho hold those
restrictions the tough border
restrictions that have been in place for
the last couple of years and they said
that djokovic failed to meet the
criteria um on entry and now djokovic he
could potentially be deported based on
this decision
the alex hawk the minister said the
decision was made on the grounds that it
was in the public interest to do so and
that djokovic posed a risk to the
australian community now the government
simply said that last week the border
forces stopped djokovic um at
tullamarine airport and questioned him
for hours uh it was his visa that was
cancelled on the thursday morning he
then spent time in the detention the
immigration detention in that hotel in
carleton uh the court then overruled the
visa cancellation and on friday around 6
p.m in melbourne this is when the
government intervened again and pursued
what the line it had always upheld uh
that these border restrictions must
remain in place and that the government
would wouldn't put in place any special
treatment for the likes of tennis stars
of like novak djokovic and as a result 6
p.m on friday that visa has been
cancelled for a second time and he does
face not just deportation but
potentially a ban on re-entering
australia for another three years
so sarah is this about him not being
vaccinated because you know of course he
he said that he had and he had covered
before
um so then i guess therefore the vac uh
the visa was exempt from the visa
because he had immunity does this mean
that you can't get into australia if you
are not vaccinated even if you've had
covert before or is this
on some other grounds
well the background to this is that
djokovic sought a medical exemption to
travel to play in the australian open
and that was approved by tennis
australia and that request for exemption
to travel and to be granted entry into
australia was approved by two panels uh
one being the medical panel or a board
of medical specialists uh of based by
the tennis australia that proved that
the government then simply said that uh
djokovic didn't meet the criteria to
enter australia because of his
unvaccinated status and i should note
that the australian open all tennis
players must be vaccinated to play
unless you get this medical exemption
now various evidence that djokovic
presented in the last couple of days in
statements released by his instagram
noted uh that he had tested positive for
covert 19 back around mid-december uh
since that uh that he was found to be
positive he did actually appear publicly
in a couple of places he also uh filled
out or one of the members of his team uh
ticked the wrong box on his australian
travel declaration on landing on entry
and the australian border forces picked
that up so he's been put a number of
false statements have been certainly
highlighted on his entry and therefore
the government says he doesn't meet the
criteria and i should also note that the
australians were polled in some polls
around australia overnight i should say
more than eighty percent of people uh
agreed that the government should deport
djokovic based on the fact that we've
had these very tough border restrictions
in place uh for the last two years and
the prime minister if he was to grant an
exemption for the likes of novak
djokovic the walls were men's number one
tennis player if they had allowed for
him to enter australia and be exempt
from some of those tough rules then that
certainly would have set a very
dangerous precedent for other people
entering australia i'm sure this isn't
the end of it uh thank you for that for
now sarah clark in brisbane